CAMERON FAN, MERRY CHRISTMAS TO
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
WELCOME TO THIS SPECIAL EDITION
OF HANNITY, I’M JASON CHAFFETZ
IN TONIGHT FOR SEAN.
BREAKING TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOLLOWED THROUGH
ON HIS THREAT TO VETO THE
$740 BILLION NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT CITING GLARING
OMISSIONS BY CONGRESS TO ADDRESS
ABUSE AND BIG TECH AND A
SCOLDING THE LEGISLATURE FOR
CRAFTING A BILL THAT CONTRADICTS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION’S
AMERICA FIRST FOREIGN POLICY.
WE’LL HAVE EXCLUSIVE REACTION
WITH NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
AMBASSADOR ROBERT O’BRIEN JUST
AHEAD.
BUT FIRST, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TONIGHT IS SHOWING GREAT
RELUCTANCE TO SIGN CONGRESSES
MASSIVE OMNIBUS SPENDING PACKAGE
AND PANDEMIC AID TO BUILD
DEMANDING THAT CONGRESS PROVIDE
DIRECT AID OF $2,000 WHO HAVE
SUFFERED UNDER NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN AND INSISTING THAT
UNNECESSARY AND WASTEFUL
SPENDING BE STRIPPED FROM THE
ONGOING APPROPRIATIONS BILL THAT
IS LARDED UP WITH PORK.
IT’S AN APPROPRIATIONS BILL THAT
NOBODY WOULD HAVE VOTED FOR IF
THEY HAD TO VOTE FOR IT BY
ITSELF.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE PRESIDENT
KEEPING HIS WORD.
BACK IN 2018, HE SAID HE WOULD
NEVER SIGN ANOTHER BILL LIKE
THIS AGAIN SAYING "IT’S NOT
RIGHT AND IT’S VERY BAD FOR OUR
COUNTRY."
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE SHOULDN’T HAVE HAD IN
THIS BILL BUT WE WERE IN A SENSE
FORCED IF WE WANT TO BUILD OUR
MILITARY, WE WERE FORCED TO
HAVE.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE IN THE BILL.
BUT I SAY TO CONGRESS, I WILL
NEVER SIGN ANOTHER BILL LIKE
THIS AGAIN, I’M NOT GOING TO DO
IT AGAIN.
NOBODY READ IT, IT’S ONLY HOURS
OLD, SOME PEOPLE DON’T EVEN
KNOW -- $1.3 TRILLION, IT’S THE
SECOND LARGEST EVER.
>> Jason: PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ELECTED TO BE A DISRUPTIVE
FORCE.
HE WAS NEVER A GO ALONG TO GET
ALONG POLITICIAN.
A TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT HE HEARS THE CALL
FROM AMERICAN PEOPLE TO STAND UP
TO THE POLITICAL CLASS AND HE
HEARS CALLS TO BUCK THE
STATUS QUO AND TO STAND UP TO
SPECIAL INTERESTS.
HIS ONLY PRIORITY HAS BEEN THAT
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND GET
THIS, THE PRESIDENT’S CALL IS
EVEN BEING WELCOMED BY HIS MOST
UNHINGED CRITICS LIKE SPEICHER
NANCY PELOSI AND CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ WHO SAY THEY ARE
READY TO BOOST THE AMOUNT OF
DIRECT PAYMENTS, SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT INSISTED ON THIS PAST
SUMMER.
HERE’S THE CORE QUESTION, WHAT
THEY ALSO AGREE TO CUT OUT THE
PORK AND ALL THE RECKLESS
SPENDING IN THE LEGISLATION WAS
MAKE THEY PROBABLY WON’T.
UNFORTUNATELY, WASTEFUL SPENDING
AND MISPLACED PRIORITIES ARE
NOTHING NEW INSIDE THE DEMOCRATS
EVER-GROWING FAR LEFT WISHLIST.
FOR EXAMPLE, REPUBLICAN
SENATOR RAND PAUL TODAY RELEASED
HIS ANNUAL AIRING OF THE
GRIEVANCES DOCUMENTING CASE
AFTER CASE OF WASTE, FRAUD, AND
ABUSE INSIDE THE SWAMP.
$15 MILLION TO BUY A HIGH SPEED
BOATS FOR SRI LANKA,
$130 MILLION TO PROMOTE
DEMOCRACY IN NEPAL.
15 MILLION TO PROMOTE IT IN
PAKISTAN, 33 BILLION TO PROMOTE
DEMOCRACY IN VENEZUELA THAT
SEEMS TO BE GOING SO WELL SO FAR
FAR.
TO BE CLEAR, NEW FUNDING BY THE
END OF THE YEAR IS IMPERATIVE TO
PREVENT A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
BUT CONGRESS HAS A CHOICE TO
MAKE, WILL THEY DELIVER NEEDED
AID TO AMERICANS STRUGGLING TO
THE PANDEMIC, OR WILL THEY
RETREAT TO THE OLD WAYS OF
WASHINGTON WHERE PORK PACKS
PROJECTS, FOREIGN NATIONS, AND